evidence my god the evidence about
mental the mental health crisis of
adolescence when Greg and I wrote the
article we were you know we saw lots of
hints that depression and anxiety were
going way up yeah and we think that's
related to the overprotection yeah okay
so let's talk about that just for a
second there go back to the book so I've
got a potential demographic explanation
over that in part well and I don't know
if you guys have looked into this or not
well there's there's two things that I
think might be contributing to it
one is two or three things one is the
average age at which children are the
average age at which people have
children's gone way up
why does that matter well because I
think people get more conservative and
cautious as they get older a little bit
but true but it's a very small effect
okay and it's wait a second okay it's
the having of the kids which is what
makes them more conservative when you
have kids you are more threat sensitive
you're more likely to vote for the
right-wing party so just delaying child
child birth wouldn't okay what about
what about fewer siblings that would yes
that's part of it and this is what we're
seeing in Asia too when you have a lot
of kids you're not quite as worried you
don't have all your eggs in one basket
well and you can you can write as
worried and the siblings raise each
other that's right right and then
there's a lot of things all night a
larkey story that's maybe not right
exactly it's the free play and the
fighting the working things out for
themselves those are essential skills of
adulthood okay so good so then all right
yeah let me take Emily sighs as part of
it right well and then also what's
happening increasingly in schools is
that kids aren't allowed free play and
they're certainly not allowed
rough-and-tumble free play would
actually that's right that's one of the
biggest things also the two that there
are three giant there are a lot of
causes it's I mean this is such actually
it's really fun puzzle because it's like
the biggest social science puzzle of our
age what is happening that's making so
many of our systems go haywire and I'm
focusing on the university the big three
I would say our one is the loss of free
of unsupervised free play yeah okay and
Peter Gray has been brilliant on this
he's at Boston College showing how even
among young animals they have to
practice the skills for adulthood yeah
and getting in cakes that's shown that -
exactly so getting in conflicts and then
dealing with it
sometimes losing and we come back having
game in which there's a problem but you
have to work it out or the game stops
that's what kids always did yeah it's
only recently the nine peaking in the
90s that they're always supervised
because we're afraid if we take our eyes
off them they'll be kidnapped and that
was never a risk that's never